foreign
my question is what brought you to LA
and how do you uh sustain minimalism
here like not just
personal clutter mental clutter
Financial clutter
so that's my there's a lot of clutter
going on here now yeah what was your
name Stacy Stacy nice to meet is this
your first time out no okay were you one
of the original yes awesome that is so
cool I came out here for these guys
plain and simple I just wanted to be
around these guys as much as possible
and and do the kind of stuff that we're
doing together and and have fun with the
adventure so I'll spend most of my time
addressing the second part of your
question like how do you do the
minimalism thing in a place like La so
three things concisely one I remember
hearing Denzel Washington in an
interview someone asked him how do you
cope with the fact that you live in
Godless Hollywood
and he says what is that Godless
Hollywood he goes Hollywood is a
geographical location speaking of
Godless Hollywood is like speaking of
Godless Nebraska or Godless Chicago but
we have this habit of applying labels to
certain places and that way we can
stereotype everyone who lives in that
geographical location as being a
particular way and I think it's very
important that when we talk about places
like La that we resist the tendency to
just lump everybody in the same category
there are a lot of people who've come
out to LA for a lot of different reasons
some of them only think about themselves
some of them love the hell out of their
families some of them are really
ambitious some of them will disappoint
you with their lack of ambition some of
them are rich some of them are broke
some of them are God filled some of them
are Godless some of them are careless
about the topic of God altogether and
we've just got to be open-minded with
how we engage people in places and not
allow our not allow ourselves to define
a place by the label we attach to the
geography but by each individual that we
encounter second thing I'll say I have a
little philosophy that's helped me out a
lot in life it's called mind your own
business and
this is something that we typically
think about when it comes to Scandal
right here's a guy that's married I'm
out to eat one day and I see him at a
restaurant with somebody that's not his
wife mind your own business TK right but
we can also apply mind your own business
to success
here's a guy that owns three Teslas he
doesn't really need three Teslas mind
your own business TK it's not your money
it's not your life it's not your job to
go around policing how well other people
are at Living their lives in accordance
with your priorities and I don't say
that as a moralist I don't say that as
something that I think you're going to
go to hell for doing I say that as an
advocate for inner peace that is very
difficult to get on with your life and
be happy with who you are and enjoy your
existence if you're constantly in
everyone else's business in terms of how
good of a job they are and are not doing
at the thing that you want to do to me
the only life worth living is the kind
of lifestyle that can be lived in an
environment where the majority of people
are not like me how powerful how
meaningful can a lifestyle be if the
only way you can implement it is if
everybody around you is just like you I
want the kind of philosophy of life that
says All of You can disagree with me you
can live completely opposite Manner and
I can still show up and be my authentic
self unthreatened by you
that's power to be
the last thing I'll say
when it comes to living in geographical
locations I talked about this on a
recent episode of the minimalist I had
this friend who back in the Blockbuster
Video days he rent a movie right and you
get like the movie for three days for
three dollars or something like that and
after he watched the movie he would
watch it again every day to get his
money's worth and I said okay do you do
this with the bad movies too and he says
yeah I says why he goes well I paid
three dollars I got it for three days so
I gotta get my money's worth and I'm
like okay but in an effort to save money
you're actually wasting your own time
and wasting your own happiness by
subjecting yourself to experiences that
you say make you miserable right and I
think that's another factor to keep in
mind when thinking about places you can
say well I'm gonna go live over there
because you can get so many square feet
for only so many dollars and it don't
cost anything yeah but if your soul
feels dead inside when you're in that
place if you're not around people that
you enjoy being around or doing work
that you enjoy doing well then are you
really saving money you might be saving
money but at the expense of your soul
there are other ways to sell your soul
besides making money you can sell your
soul in an effort to save money and so
minimalism isn't about saving money or
making money it isn't about having more
stuff we're getting rid of stuff it's
about making sure that I don't sell my
soul in the way that I establish my
relationship to stuff
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free